foreign
[Laughter]
just your arms looking better now yeah
Jenny's got her new uh Ultra nerd
glasses on that I gave her my Uber nerd
glass yeah I gave her those as a gift I
said what were the cutest nerdiest
glasses and it was like those little
where's Waldo glasses
yeah I'm kind of into them turn a little
bit sideways Jazz AC so yeah that's her
where's Waldo glasses I said all my
glasses I have there on like a like a
spectrum of nerdiness yeah and these are
probably like the Uber nerdiness ones
but that's okay yeah we did erotic photo
shoot with those glasses on yeah I did I
did different photos like with different
glasses and no glasses white wig and
those they look cute
and I did a red wig too yeah like the
short
yeah so uh so yeah so xanada is here and
we are talking about another movie that
xanada sent us which I was really
excited about because I love this movie
yeah and I had not seen this I think I
saw this in the theater
um if I didn't see it in the theater
then I rented it very very shortly after
it came out and watched it and I just
remember loving this movie and I hadn't
seen it I don't think I'd seen it since
then so I was very excited to revisit it
and we watched it last night did you
realize that this movie I think this
movie is like three hours long it didn't
seem that long to me yeah the um xanadas
in there now I just wanted to say
something before the show started I was
working with him I'd send him a gift of
some uh long cult uh A2 hand guards off
m16a2
and a pistol grip he's putting that on
his PSA he's made a [__] really cool
clone it's the same I got one of them
too I got the same clone but it's a it's
a PSA Palmetto State Armory again clone
of a Bushmaster A4 carbine with the
class will stock on it it looks sweet as
[__] and he's got these parts that he
ended up with got the PSA mistakenly
sent in some [__] a long time ago they
didn't ask for it back so he just kept
it uh because they said in the wrong
shipment and then man I think by looking
at it man that's that [__] five pound
enhanced trigger that's in there
uh and that buffer I think might it's
it's got the white buffer end which is
something exotic it's either nine
millimeter or it's stuck in some kind of
tungsten buffer
um so we had to identify what that is
after the show but you could probably
install you could install that trigger
I'd install that trigger that's by the
color of that trigger something's been
treated that's that polished enhanced
trigger it's just this mil-spec one but
it's polished enhanced five pound pull
got all the reliability of the mil-spec
one they were only 40 bucks but that
saves you 40 bucks because that's what
you were asking for I think that I think
that's what that is
I didn't see uh the color doesn't look
normal
I'd install it it could you it couldn't
be bad
um worst case scenario to be the same
one you just took out
but other than that we'll figure it out
okay it's his video he sent us this
movie Casino so I'm gonna help him with
his gun
and he's he's live right in there yeah
yeah and like I said I was really
excited to get this one I mean I'm
excited to get all the movies that we
get from you guys but I was really
excited about this one because I hadn't
seen it in a long time and I remember
really liking it and you would also you
had never seen it right never seen it I
thought I saw it until I started
watching this man I've ever seen this
well it's kind of a lot of people like
um say it's kind of similar to
Goodfellas which I guess it kind of is
uh particularly Joe Pesci's character
and I think that was the main this got
when it came out in 1995. I feel like um
you know it was mostly it's Martin
Scorsese so he's gonna get like you know
uh all the critics are gonna love this
[__] but I think a lot um the main
criticism that a lot of them had was
that it was too similar to Goodfellas
like it so it wasn't like he was playing
it safe and he was like treading the
same ground or whatever but it's like I
don't I don't know I don't know if I
would really yeah it's like look Martin
Score says he is into like making
gangster movies yeah and that's just his
thing and so I don't yeah it's similar
thematically I guess to Goodfellas but
it's different enough that okay
yeah that's what I mean so it's just
kind of like what are you gonna do about
it because I think Goodfellas came out
what like 1990 right so yeah so it was
like the movie that came out either one
or two before this one
but um so yeah this was actually based
on real events now some of this stuff
was changed and they did change a lot of
the people's names
um but that said I was watching um a
video earlier there's this guy
that um does these really uh you know
these these really in-depth breakdowns
of movies that are based on historical
events or like real people and talks in
depth about like how accurate they are
and so he did uh one on this one and
he's like yeah other than a few details
and other than some of the game like
names being changed and like some
characters being combined and stuff this
is fairly accurate
um to the real life events of what
happened and this basically stretches
from I believe the event started in like
1973 somewhere around there and um go
until like the 80s
so this was based on a book that uh also
came out in 1995 and it was by a guy
named Nicholas palegi and the um the
book was called Casino love and honor in
Las Vegas and so the guy that wrote the
book was also like co-wrote screenplay
with Martin Scorsese and uh as I said
they I think the reason that they chose
to like change everyone's names is they
didn't maybe they didn't really want to
get in trouble or something because they
did have actual Mafia people that were
Consultants like on this movie but one
interesting thing that they did even
though it's pretty clear watching the
movie that the mob that they're talking
about is the Chicago Mafia
but as far as I can remember nobody ever
refers to the Chicago Mafia in the movie
because if you notice like Robert De
Niro's character Ace like he always they
always say like back home they never say
Chicago
um I think they even changed some of the
action like you know the the old guys
that they send the skimmed money back to
I think they set that in Kansas City but
this is actually the Chicago Mafia that
they're talking about because that was
who
um funded these casinos like I said this
is a pretty accurate
representation of what really happened
with some minor changes I guess but so
the character that Robert De Niro plays
uh Ace rosting or Sam Rothstein who's
called Ace is based on a real dude uh
Frank Lefty Rosenthal
yeah yeah man we were watching this
movie
and I this is this character man I I
like this character I don't know how
closely he's based on the original guy
similar it's similar
man I like the guy and then all of a
sudden he does something that no real
player would do and that's Mary a hooker
as soon as that happened I'm like no
dude what are you doing what are you
doing you're letting a Viper into the
nest and that's exactly what happened
Jenny saw it coming too I mean well I've
seen this movie before Oh you saw it
dude's downfall like yeah what's he
thinking well like I said I think the
the movie has it set up that that's like
his tragic flaw or that he actually
genuinely loved her yeah even though she
was uh less than trustworthy let's put
it that way yeah she's an interesting
character I don't know how close she's
based on the real one
um but similar but they actually it
seems like they made her worse in the
movie okay she wasn't quite that bad
okay in real life so it kind of doesn't
matter I mean [__]
as as the story starts to unfold you
find out that the the PIP got a hold of
her and turned her out when she was 14
and like a grooming kind of thing yeah
and and like uh dude [__] had total
control over her no matter where she was
and she's kind of sympathetic in the
fact that it's not her fault that this
happened to her but you can't trust her
yeah uh that's no you know [__]
that's she was a predator basically
basically whether she was trying to be
nice or not it didn't matter
she was loyal to that dude he
brainwashed her from an early age you
know so you just
no man
that's a hooker crazy and he can even
after she did like some really rotten
[__] like he kept taking taking her back
yeah which like I said that I think that
but that's what made it interesting to
me because that was like his fatal fly
yes well it wasn't fatal because he
spoiler alert he makes it through like
pretty much unscathed yeah but um yeah
everybody everybody else gets killed but
she is hot she's sophisticated she seems
to be like High Caliber in high class
but she's not like a street walker she's
just like a casino Hustler
but you you know as the story got you
know you just can't get that out of
there and get you can't get that out of
her you know what I mean it's just she's
not built for family life that's not
the deal there he gets he just wanted he
thought she was cool
but uh yeah he just no he seemed to like
fall Head Over Heels a lot with her so
much so that he was willing to marry her
even though she's straight up said hey I
don't love you yeah yeah and he tried he
thought he could reason his way in in
the no and she's like it's not really
for me
her main ability and if you ever know
girl Jenny and I know at least one of
those girls there's some other ones
probably too that are have a background
like that they're chameleons you'd never
suspect that that's what they do for a
living
and they they they basically manipulate
men for a living and uh that's what she
does she tried to get dudes to kill it
to try to get dude to kill her husband
and just by Sleeping with this one and
sleeping with that one and throwing
crosses and [__] just
no yeah xanadas said was it the history
Buffs Channel yeah that's what it is I
love that guy like yeah he's awesome
that that channel is uh is good and he
like I said he really goes like an
in-depth he's a British guy and Xander
also said I know Sharon Stone is kind of
a villainous character in this but she
was so good yeah this actually showed
that she could actually act
um you know what I mean because she was
really good in this I think she got a
Golden Globe for this too and got
nominated for an Oscar as far as I know
she was the only actor that got
nominated for an Oscar for this movie
but I was gonna say that so her
character whose name is ginger in the
movie
she's based on Lefty rosenthal's real
life wife whose name was actually Jerry
now as far as I'm aware Jerry was not a
prostitute
um she was a showgirl and a model she
was like a swimsuit model or something
like that
um I don't know about her being a
hustler or anything but um but but
that's kind of how they met and even
though some of the [__] in the movie
like she did do that and she did
actually die of like a drug overdose
because she was like a big uh like
alcoholic and drug addict and stuff like
that she did die just like they showed
in the movie just like in some La
fleabag hotel
um like she I think she was only 46 like
she died of an overdose
um in the 80s I think it was 1982. but
what they did not put in the movie was
that one uh the guy who James Woods
plays in the movie
um Lester diamond or whatever his
character's name is
um he was not a pimp uh he was her
former boyfriend
um and she actually had a kid with him
she had a daughter which they didn't put
in the movie
and she did like give him money and [__]
like that but like I said it's I don't
think he wasn't her pimp and like I
don't know if there was that whole
grooming like they met when she was 14
or whatever
um she just did that for the movie to
make it more jokes yeah I'm not really
sure if that was going on or not but as
far as I know that wasn't going on
because like I said I don't think he was
a pimp but um in the context of this
story [__] uh what's his name uh
Silverstein or Rose what was the guy's
name Sam who the real guy or the
Rothstein Ross team that's the
character's name that's the character's
name yeah Ross team he's the fake one
yeah yeah he still should have known
better man come on he's well and they
what I was gonna get his pick of the
letter anyway was running [__] one of
the biggest biggest casinos there and
well that's what we were saying it's
like dudes are thinking with the little
head why that one they got another one
you know you must have a mentality of
abundance there's a lot of them there's
a lot of them don't focus in on just on
what chick talk about and the thing
about it too is that in the movie they
made her kind of seem like a lot more
like a like a crazy person and
everything like that but what they
didn't uh say was that actually
allegedly Frank Rosenthal
um the real guy was uh quite abusive to
her and was like a lot more controlling
than they show in the movie like in the
movie yeah he makes her wear a beeper
but that's like after she's already like
had a [__] meltdown and left and then
come back and and he thinks she's
[__] around like with the old
boyfriend and stuff which she was which
she was and um and [__] like that so but
they're like in real life uh he was way
worse than that like way before that
like he had like a whole schedule of
like [__] she had to do every day and
it's like he kept track of like every
single movement and everything now she
did have an affair with the friend the
enforcer who Joe Pesci plays in the
movie Nikki
um so that did happen in in real life
Joe Pesci's [__] funny man he was so
good in uh in uh [__]
Good Fellas he pulled that roll-offs so
well they kind of got Typecast yeah but
he's so good at playing those kind of
rolls though and he's great in this one
too he's actually for a little dude yes
but the real life guy that he's playing
was was little too he was a little short
fella yeah he they called him the ants
the real life guy because he because he
was yeah he was about the same height as
Joe Patrick I meant the short guy Mafia
too I'm like five six I think pesh she's
even a lot shorter than me but it's
funny how he got Typecast as a little
[__] hot-headed dude a lot a lot of
short guys are hot-headed uh because you
take it you grew up taking [__] off of
[__] dudes all the time
but you had to fight to fight to keep
your head above water but in this one
man he is funny
he's pretty much plays the same
character as he does isn't good Fellas
yeah and I think a lot of people
complain but it's just kind of funny how
in this one you know it's just his
[__] cruelty he'll just call somebody
a [__] he'll just punch him
right in the face in in public
and and he's beating up dudes in their
60s and [__] yeah he does not give a
single phone and everybody it's his in
the end though and he dies miserably at
the end but man that I had forgotten
that was what it's weird you'd think
that I would remember this yeah but I
had forgotten how [__] brutal some of
the [__] scenes in this are holy [__]
yeah he died almost like a Mexican
Mexican Mob style that is you know
[__] up it watched him kill his they
made him watch as they killed his
brother beat him to death with baseball
bats and he didn't die then they just
buried him both alive while they were
alive they were all busted up
uh it was pretty good scene they did out
in a damn cornfield
now that was a little bit of an
exaggeration the two guys that did
happen in real life um you know the guy
and his brother and they did get bumped
off uh they didn't kill him in a
cornfield they killed him in a basement
somewhere in like Illinois or Iowa or
someplace and I don't think they beat
them with baseball bats I think they
just beat them to death with their fists
yeah
um and then they did bury them in a
cornfield however uh they didn't
actually look as cool in the movies
that's why well yeah that's what I mean
and baseball bat I think they were
referring back like Martin Score says he
was referring back to like one of his
other movies so it was that too but and
that and the scene that I think
everybody remembers too is when they
crushed that dude's head in device which
uh which did happen in real life
um he killed him by slit in his throat
yeah um and actually in real life they
did put the dude's head in the vice like
to get him to um say someone's name but
in the movie like you said they slashed
his throat to like put him out of his
misery in real life they set him on fire
yeah that happens sometimes and I think
they did also stab him in the balls with
an ice pick I think they didn't show
that the movie but they did say that
they did that she won purification by
fire
I've been around been around since the
Middle Ages even the scene where they
find the guy that's like cheating in the
casino and they just like beat his
[__] hand with a hammer even that is
just like holy [__] man I had forgotten
how [__] up oh they could do that
because they weren't gonna go to the
cops not back in those days they were
gonna go to the car oh they hit me with
the hammer for cheating right you know
what I mean because those dudes were
professional cheats they were gangsters
they couldn't go to the cops yeah and
they could never [__] face the
criminal underworld again if they did so
they just punish them by breaking their
hands up with [__]
hammers
and one dude yeah yeah and the other guy
they [__] picked him up and [__]
bashed the doors open with his head
taking his shoes off and putting his
shoes up and putting his feet up on the
table [__] yeah yeah and one of the one
of the Cowboys that's like working in
the in the um thing because there was a
whole like plot Thread about uh you know
all of these Cowboys that were related
to various politicians and stuff and
they had to be given these jobs in the
casinos even though they weren't any
good at anything and one of those guys I
was like that was Joe Bob Briggs wasn't
that Joe Bob Briggs yeah like playing
one of the characters that got like
fired because they said he was an idiot
because somebody hit like three things
on the on the slot machine and he's in
the and Robert's here got mad because
he's like why didn't you notice
xanadas said yeah and Goodfellas Joe
Pesci kills Billy bats yeah that's right
played by Frank Vincent so in Casino
Frank Vincent kills Joe Pesci with the
battle oh well yeah that's a yeah it was
like a trade-off but um but yeah so his
character is [__] great in this and
uh he was talking about too the um the
scene at the end where uh where Sharon
Stone like drives her car up to the
house at the end and she's like [__]
flipping out she man she [__] went
for it in this movie I feel like she'd
been in movies before this obviously
because she was in Basic Instinct and
all that kind of stuff but I think she
was maybe and maybe this because I kind
of remember that she had a reputation
for just being kind of like the hot
chick from Basic Instinct that showed
everybody her cooch yeah and so like not
really taken seriously as an actress so
I think that when this movie came out
real serious that's like it really I
think a lot of people did
also in Total Recall that's right I
forgot about that there's a lot of a lot
of cool movies that were out when I was
growing up and Sharon Stone was a thing
get out of it [__] she was hot you
know [__] and it's in my late teens
and [__] she was an older woman I was
like man I wish I could hit and all guys
my age that I knew were like that like
man she's badass
she's kind of like a passing fad five
years later you kind of forgot about her
at least we did
yeah no one's Kane
's new one yeah babe of the month would
show up you know dudes man they just
yeah they throw them away just like
Popsicles or whatever
[Laughter]
um Camp guy said I got to see this again
the gambling cheaters is one of my
favorite scenes all the scenes in this
are good this is just like I said I
think this movie is like three hours
long but it didn't even seem like that
to me because and it's weird because
Martin Score says he himself said oh
this movie doesn't really have a plot
which I don't know if I agree with that
no it's got a block but it does have a
plot but that's the thing it's just kind
of like it's it's a summation of like
more than a decade of like [__] that
happened and yeah it's like a super
complicated story because there's like a
lot of characters and you know so you
kind of have to keep track of what
what's going on with everybody but I
guess I guess I see what he's talking
about it doesn't really have a plot per
se it's just a story they're telling you
yeah because like I said it's largely
based on a real based on a real thing
unreal [__] that happens like like I
said they changed everyone's names but
it's not hard to find out like who the
actual people that is based on are right
by that by that measure you could say
Goodfellas didn't have a plot it was
just what happened
the story yeah you know so but you don't
notice it when you're watching it you
just you get sucked into it yeah and the
thing about it yeah and the the thing
about it too is that because we because
you were saying when the um the the
casino that that uh Sam Rosenthal runs
in the movie is called the Tangiers and
you were like that's not a real casino
is it and I'm just like no I don't think
it is it's not it was actually based on
the Stardust okay uh the Stardust was
actually one of the real guy uh Lefty
Rosenthal he actually owned he actually
ran four casinos uh one of which was the
Stardust he also ran the Fremont the
Marina and the Hacienda like in Las
Vegas and he ran it for the Chicago mob
but I guess they made it so that it
would be like simpler just like focused
around one casino and they actually did
shoot it in a real Casino as well like
during hours when it wasn't that crowded
because they're like you know why build
a set when you can just go in there and
film it in a real actual thing yeah but
that's the thing so
um so yeah I do kind of feel like
kuzanna said too that like the car
bombing thing didn't happen either yeah
that's true and the funny thing about it
is that Lefty Rosenthal he's dead now he
died in 2008 I think
but um you know he was uh Robert De
Niro's character he saw this movie
and he actually really dug it the only
thing that he said that he didn't like
about it was the scene where because you
know what the part like toward the end
of the movie where uh Robert De Niro
like they they do the TV show which in
the movie is called Aces High but in
real life it was just called the Frank
Rosenthal show and they actually had
like big stars on there like Frank
Sinatra was on there Don Rickles was on
there um you know he would interview
people and they'd have like little bands
and like disco dancers and all that kind
of [__] yeah so he's like there was one
scene in there where Robert De Niro is
like on the TV show and he's juggling
and Frank Rosenthal um kind of took
offense at that because he's like it
made me look stupid and he's like and I
never would have juggled on the TV show
so he was like kind of offended the
thing but that was like the only quibble
that he had with the movie I think which
I thought was really funny it seemed
like so nitpicky for just like a random
one-off kind of scene there where you
been grampton yeah that's right yeah
yeah grafter said the plot is when Vegas
was run by gangsters not corporations
yeah and that's kind of like it's kind
of like an end of an era type situation
like I said because it starts in the 70s
like the early 70s and then goes into
like the 80s when you know when the
mafia kind of got run out like everybody
kind of got rubbed out or got run out of
Vegas on a rail and then all like I said
all the cop corporations took over and
they actually showed at the end like
some of the old
um casinos like being demolished which
the scene that they show at the end with
the casino being demolished that was
real footage of one of the old casinos
being demolished and then you know like
the junk bond uh the money from junk
bonds like took over like all the
corporations bought it out and turned it
into like they said it turned it into
Disneyland or something like that which
you know what I mean
and even that Santa is talking about an
equal amount of blueberries in each
muffin yeah and that's
um that's based on real life too uh
apparently people said that Frank
Rosenthal was like super controlling
like that and he did have the thing
where it's like each muffin that was
served in that casino had to have the
same amount of blueberries in it
um so they're like that was actually
based on real life so even though they
did exaggerate some [__] and like I said
they changed a couple things out too
like I said they kind of made
um Sharon Stone's character Ginger they
made her out like a little bit worse
than she was in real life and like I
said kind of made Robert De Niro's
character a little bit more sympathetic
like in the sense that he didn't because
he didn't really start like smack her
around until the end part where she like
tied the kid to the bed yeah you know
what I mean and then like he kind of
smacked around after that but apparently
in real life like he'd been smacking
around like pretty much the whole entire
time and was like super controlling and
everything now the [__] where
um in real life like I said she had a
daughter with uh the Lester Diamond
character guy who I can't remember what
his real name was but um he was kind of
like a low level he wasn't a pimp but he
was kind of like his scumbag a little
bit
and they had a daughter and then with uh
with her husband Frank Rosenthal who's
Robert De Niro's character they actually
had two kids they had a son and a
daughter and um at one point her and the
boyfriend did kidnap those two kids so
that was what so that was kind of
because in the movie they show them like
kidnapping the daughter and that so that
really actually did happen they're gonna
run from dude right right right and
that's so so a lot of the [__] in there
like I said all the arrangement that
they had about the marriage where she
basically straight up told him look I
don't love you and he's like yeah but
I'll take care of you your whole entire
life and you have to and but the
stipulation was that he had she had to
marry him and he had to know where she
was all the time and she had to have
children because he wanted children yeah
so she agreed to it even though he knew
that she wasn't really as like into him
in the same way and like I said she was
[__] around with um
you know with the Joe Pesci character
who wasn't that that obviously wasn't
like that in real life but I have seen
Joe Pesci doesn't look super like the
real guy he sort of does like the real
guy who like I said I can't remember his
name was but I know they called him the
ant that was like his nickname because
he was short but he was like about the
same size as Joe Pesci and he kind of
had because Joe Pesci had that little
white like that gray streak in his hair
yeah the dude did have that
um but he had kind of had more of a
mustache and he looked a little bit
different but he did use a lot of his
mannerisms they said he had that thing
where he like chewed on his thumb all
the time and all that kind of stuff so
he did like have the same mannerisms as
him and they said that
um the real guy like when Joe Pesci came
in like in the costume and like in
character some of the people that were
working in the casino that knew that had
known that guy in real life they just
about wet their [__] pants because
they were terrified of that dude yeah
um so it's like when he came in it was
like have like PTSD flashbacks or some
[__] like that so so like I said Joe
Pesci in this even though he's like
small dude he comes across as like
really
ruthless and like really terrifying so
you can see how this little dude in real
life like I said in real life people
were [__] terrified of him because he
did do a bunch of that [__] like he just
did not give a single [__] about
just killing people and he got and that
was kind of that's kind of one of the
conflicts in the movie too is that he
just didn't really he got like kind of
stupid and careless about just killing
people and not giving a [__] about if
the cops were gonna come or anything
like that because I think he just
thought he was going to get away with
[__] forever yeah he was [__] with
the FBI in the movie right he liked
[__] with them yeah he had all the
same surveillance equipment and
everything
that they had yeah and if they were
watching him he'd go there and he'd
start watching them back
yeah he likes to play with them yeah he
seemed like real cocky yeah Tony
spelotra that's right that's what his
name was thank you xanada because I
couldn't remember I remembered that they
called him the aunt but I couldn't
remember what his real name was
but yeah that was that was his real name
murder Hornet said didn't he give her a
beeper yeah yeah
murder Hornet also says a little
smacking around is okay
well I don't know about that but you
know what I mean in the context of the
movie though she was she was violent too
she you know yeah I don't think like I
said they did make him more sympathetic
in the movie and you didn't really blame
him when he kind of like he didn't
really smack her around at that point he
was just like really mad because he had
she had gone out with the boyfriend and
was like totally [__] hammered and
she had straps their daughter to the bed
like while the kid was sleeping so the
kid like wakes up like in the house by
herself like strapped to the [__] bed
and she's like yelling for help and [__]
like that there are couples [__] out
there man you go to the hood
and they're [__] both the guy and the
girl both Psychopaths you know and she's
just as violent as he is I mean [__]
sometimes those girls will actually kill
the dude you know we've seen that before
it's true crime stuff but uh they'll
kill she'll kill the dude you'll be
asleep she'll shoot him while he's
asleep just all kinds of [__]
yeah I mean just because it's a woman
doesn't mean that
you can't beat smack her around
especially if she's abusive as [__] if
she's a psycho and you're a psycho
they're gonna get beat on each other
well yeah so you see that sometimes yeah
no it's not normal absolutely not normal
a normal woman would run from a
situation like that but usually that
kind of woman they thrive on it they
[__] it's almost like say to
masochism and they're they're evil too
whether or not you know a lot of times
it's probably something that was built
into them at an early age
get a bad family life and upbringing
abusive
and they just kind of Thrive off of it
that's all they know yeah that's kind of
what's tragic about it is that if you're
raised in an environment like that like
you don't know any different you just
kind of think oh that's how people yeah
it is relate to one another and that's
just how the world is so it's like
everybody just [__] smacks everybody
else around and
that's you just got to beat them up
before they beat you up you know yeah
that's love which yeah and like I said
that's [__] up I think that that's
love that's [__] up but if that's all
that you know and that's all that's been
modeled for you then yeah that's what
you're gonna think because how would you
know any different we know a girl like
that that if you're not [__] super
controlling to her and basically
mentally and emotionally abusive then
you don't love her
yeah and I've known yeah and I've known
some women like that yeah because like I
said that's it's all like how they're
brought up and it's like really sad yeah
if you're nice to her she's just she is
a chop and just go find some dude who'll
abuse her yeah yeah it's sad it's like
it makes me really sad it's all they
know but I've known like several several
women like that
um
uh yeah murder horn said the fed's
playing ran out of gas and yeah like
landed on The Fairway that happened in
real life too that happened in real life
too that was like they said yeah that
scene like seems really silly and like
ridiculous but that did happen in real
life I thought the funniest thing to me
was the little offhand thing at the end
where the plane lands and the two feds
are like running like oh [__] we ran out
of gas and then Joe Pesci just goes a
hundred dollars for the first one that
hits that plane and then like they shirt
chunky like like they sure start hitting
like golf balls at it I just thought
that was like super funny this is a
great movie it is great it is it's like
much better than I remembered yeah I'd
never seen it uh I think it's as good as
Good Fellas
um
not quite as good as the Godfather part
two but still good real good
and I saw scorsese's last one that they
did remember the one it also had the
Irishman the Irishman yeah which
actually has a little bit because that
was more about Jimmy Hoffa yeah but it
has references to the [__] that happened
in this movie you know that one was
pretty good too
um I think this one was better than than
the Irishman um there were certain parts
of the Irishman that I was like man I
cannot believe that they did that they
took uh denir and de-aged him but then
they had him in fight scenes and it's
obviously an old man
that was really the only thing that like
bothered me about it because I actually
did really like that movie there's no
reason why they didn't have a damn body
double
do that fight scene you know what I mean
and then just superimpose [__] what's
his head on it yeah or just shoot it in
a way where you never really see where
you don't say the face you know because
I don't think anybody would expect like
an aging actor to be out there like
doing it yeah and it's obviously he's
moving like an old man if I can De Niro
man those guys that guy's old now he's
old yeah that's not he's not a mature
guy he's old yeah
um
his acting was pretty good in in the
Irishman
and the the de-aging that they did on
him actually was pretty good it was
decent I mean it's still slightly on
Candy Valley but you're gonna get that
you know pretty good I think I know
Scorsese in that one he wanted to do
like the big last hurray you know with
big names and stuff I would have done it
I would have used newer Talent
yeah maybe so but the thing about it I
mean him and Robert De Niro have how
many movies have they done together
eight nine something you could put
DeNiro in it just don't make him the
[__]
the lead guy
or well what they could have done is
they could have had like in the present
day like it be Robert De Niro but then
like have a younger actor like instead
of like de-aging
could have done that too I mean you
could have that would have been the
easiest route to go because like I said
nobody's gonna and I think people are
still weirded out by the de-aging thing
like Yeah it's gotten a lot better but
it's still like a little bit weird
because you know that that's not them
that whole de-aging thing makes a movie
feel like inauthentic if you ask
I wish they would just get a younger
actor that looks like him yeah it's been
a lot better and then they could have
used him they could have used dinero in
the movie when he was older
as the character ages
but practical effects man and just
acting yeah that's always that's always
going to be better than any kind of CGI
kind of [__] yeah yeah Xander said the
scene where Pesci threatens the banker
oh my God so great and I actually love
the scene too like near the beginning of
the movie where you first kind of
realize what a psychopath Joe Pesci is
when they're just at a bar and this guy
just kind of like insults Robert De Niro
for no reason and like [__] Joe Pesci
just like starts stabbing the [__] out
of his neck like with a pen yeah and
it's just like blood but I don't think
he didn't kill the dude but because this
guy was like laying there moaning or
whatever but that was kind of like the
first time that you knew because it just
kind of came out of nowhere and he's
just like [__] and everyone's just
stand around going huh well that's
that's just how that goes
granther says it would have been great
to see Vegas back when gangsters ran it
and the Rat Pack played every night now
I can't wait to leave after two days of
crappy buffets and soulless car dealers
yeah I mean I've never been to Vegas
personally uh my brother's been a bunch
of times and he actually kind of likes
it there but I've never been it doesn't
really seem like my kind of thing to be
honest with you but I don't know I might
have a good time there I don't like to
gamble that's what I mean you know
because I don't have any money and it's
like I don't really want to lose what
little [__] money I have just pissing
it away like that I'd rather piss it
away on booze you know what I'm saying I
guess you can do that [__] [__] Vegas
yeah I just it like I said it just
doesn't seem like my kind of thing I'd
rather go to [__] Biloxi
there's a lot of places I'd rather go
before I went to Vegas and Like I said
no no shame if people like that kind of
thing but it's like I'm because I think
my sister's been too and she thought it
was kind of cool [__] Biloxi though
was [__] you could gamble there and
they had nice [__] but it was just it
wasn't it didn't have it doesn't have
that [__] corporate feel it's not as
big it's a smaller [__] crowd but
it's still high-end and it had good food
and you know Pirate Bay [__] Harris
oh they had they had good casinos there
we just and you weren't overpowered by
it you could get away from it right you
know what I mean but then again you know
Vegas is like going to an amusement park
but maybe that's what if you're looking
for that then that's yeah and now
there's nothing wrong with amusement
parks I like going to like amusement
parks I'm just saying that it's like
it's a lot that's all it's a lot but
that's kind of like the whole thing it's
like over the top and like ostentatious
yeah that's kind of what that's their
whole yeah marketing Biloxi Biloxi's
low-key you know what I mean it's not in
your face hookers wall-to-wall hookers
and [__] I don't know if it's still like
that in Vegas it used to be nothing but
just [__]
lizards [__] looking for the winners
and [__] latching on to them you know
going up to your hotel with some dudes
are into that though you know but well
yeah and like I said no shame if that's
kind of what you if you're into that
kind of [__] then okay knock yourself
out you're not hurting nobody just you
know it's not really my thing though
yeah but um well you can gamble in
Florida you just you go over to uh
Lakeland or you know halfway to Tampa
and you go over there and you go to the
they got Seminole Indian Reservation
okay and they got a big huge [__]
Casino how far is that from here
um not far maybe maybe 50 miles maybe
not even that far we'll go
I like to play with roulette because you
know like every time we drive to Tampa
which we haven't done in a while but
every time you drive to Tampa you see
like the big signs for I think it's in
Lakeland okay which is about halfway in
between but yeah it's not far I like
maybe maybe an hour like roulette I like
Blackjack
duh
actually if you really want to win you
want to do poker you don't want to play
against the house you're going to play
against other players and the house gets
something gets a cut of the winnings you
know what I mean the then you gotta
that's they had in Biloxi had people
living in them motorhomes they just park
there in the dam
uh parking lot and they would just go to
the [__]
poker tables and just watch and they
would looking for and they'd do that
[__] all season looking for weak players
and then they go to that table and then
just clean them out and then go back to
the parking lot and go back to the
motorhome
which technically that's not really
cheating I mean it's not it's not card
counting it's not doing anything like
it's in the it's in the rules yeah you
can do that and you're not playing
against the house you're playing against
other players
yeah which is always because when you
play against the house I mean they have
the whole thing it's rigged set up yeah
too and they even say that in this movie
that it's like basically you play long
enough you're gonna lose all your
[__] [__] your only chance is a
[__] long term playing against the
house is Blackjack
you got a chance but you got to be good
at it and there's a certain bets playing
on the outside if you're patient
roulette the odds are slightly in your
favor
and if your luck is good that day you
could come up some like go in there I've
got in there with a hundred dollars and
then walked out with three hundred but
the thing is is that you has to have to
do it kind of quick within a couple
hours and you have to have a [__]
limit you say when I triple my money I'm
out
if you continue to play you're going to
lose it yeah okay and I think well
that's kind of the thing with like
people that have gambling addictions
they always think oh well the next one
I'm gonna win all this money no you're
gonna lose your shirt is what's gonna
happen the longer you stay in there the
more money you're gonna lose and that's
why I just never like I said it's not
like I have all this disposable income
anyway so it's like I always you know I
grew up kind of poor so I'm always like
used to hanging on to my [__] money
and I don't like to spend it on stuff
yeah so even like if I might need some
[__] but so I'm definitely not gonna
just like piss it away on like a dice
roll or like a [__] card game first
time I won money was that the roulette
table I just bet on black I put 20 on
black came back forty dollars in the
next [__] roll I said I'm gonna put
this 40 on black came back 80. and I was
like whoa walked away from it I can't
believe it and then
and then the [__] roulette dealer
[__] asked me for a tip and I said
hold on I'm gonna play again and then I
started playing that outsides and then I
got up to about 150. and I gave the
[__] I said I got to get out of here
because I started with 20. I've made too
much [__] money I gave the [__]
dealer to think 20 30 bucks thank you
and [__] walked out of there with the
with the chips if you stay you're gonna
lose your [__] money that's the game
yeah I mean the whole no one to lose the
whole city is engineered to just take
your money away as soon as you [__]
more than tripled your money you get the
[__] out of there You're Gonna Lose It
yeah just odds are against you go and
buy some blow have a good time
just go home
for me at the time chunk of the rent
that I was
right so that yeah you're like that's
what I would think I'm like oh well [__]
I'm gonna quit I'm gonna quit while I'm
ahead I can actually like pay half the
rent it's like half my rent
xanadas said I live near Reno which is
basically mini Vegas Vegas is okay the
hotels are nice we have slot machines in
grocery stores here haha
and then granther says I'll take Reno
any day over Vegas Lake Tahoe is the
[__] and xanadas said yeah Lake Tahoe is
amazing I've never been there either but
yeah I've heard that's really like uh
really cool and xanadas said the house
from Godfather too is in Lake Tahoe and
then also says I only play roulette if I
gamble but I have friends who win a lot
of money playing craps yeah craps is a
good one too there was a couple crap
bets I used to do but I forgot about I
forgot which ones they were because I
didn't play it long enough to really get
it ingrained in me but there are some
dudes that can really [__] there I
think what they call it play in the play
in the corners or what was it there's
certain bets that you can do on crafts
they think you can bet against other
players too you can bet that that
someone's gonna lose that's that's
another one that I but I forgot how it
went
you could bet that somebody's gonna crap
out there's all kinds of weird [__]
Grandfather said I had 20K once at the
MGM Grand Casino in Detroit on a 20 slot
machine yeah holy [__] what are the odds
of that happening slot machines are
total
[__] I think what they're doing from
my understanding is that they're
watching the players from the camera
through the cameras and they'll pick a
player to hit
and it's okay you give him some money
and uh then you continue to play more
because you want some and then they'll
just bleed to dry
they're selecting who's going to get hit
holy [__] if I win twenty thousand
dollars I'd be like I'm getting the [__]
out of here right now with my twenty
thousand dollars I am not I am not
betting any more of this I'm hoarding it
yeah I'm hoarding it that's how I do
because I'd be like holy [__] that's
never gonna happen again but see that's
why I don't have a gambling addiction
because if you had a gambling addiction
they'd be like I'm gonna take this 20K
I'm gonna turn it into 100k I'm gonna be
like no I'm absolutely not doing that I
have twenty thousand dollars right now
I'm leaving yeah I can buy a [__] car
with this I remember when they were made
gambling legal in Mississippi and it
started to go so all the religious
[__] groups in Central Mississippi
for protesting that gambling destroys
lives and no they're just going on or
not about a lot of things destroy lives
it's going to make the state poor yeah
right [__] all the money [__]
Biloxi is making all the money that's
really the only thing of any
significance in Mississippi's [__]
Biloxi past Christiane and [__] um
Long Beach Mississippi it's because the
casino industry there
and uh no
people make out like Bandits the people
playing
are not locals
you know what I mean you're saying yeah
so you're taking from tourists they're
coming yeah they're coming around the
area right you know restaurants popping
up and everything so all this
[__]
what do you call them [__] Southern
Baptist [__] bellyaching over [__]
the sins of gambling now the [__] out of
here I mean I don't have an issue
they're not hurting anybody yeah uh
other than maybe themselves it's games
yeah it's just games and games and
they're coming with money and I mean if
they come there with money and they lose
it all yeah that's kind of on them yeah
they're like yeah but that's money they
should be spending on their family well
they well they should but they're not
like you can't make them yeah you can't
make people do do what you can't make
people spend the money on their family
and half those [__] [__] who
are addicted to gambling don't have any
families that they long lost that I was
gonna say their family's probably [__]
up look at that it's like being a drug
addict you know what I mean they're like
yeah I'm not dealing with this [__] show
anymore bye and the vast majority of
people that gamble are not like a
gambling addict they're not like that
well some people are real strategic
about it they'll go all over the country
and like make money in that way they're
touring around
the country playing not against the
house but against other card players
Xander said sports betting is big in
Nevada too and I think that they went
into I mean I'm not sure how
historically accurate this is because I
mean the movie because you know Casino
was you know pretty accurate as far as
that goes like historically but they did
have
um they did mention in this movie that
the Tangiers which in real life is the
Stardust was the first casino to have
like all the sports betting [__] in the
casino and then like all the other
casinos like started copying that so I
think that might be fairly accurate yeah
some of those days some days I think it
might have been at Pirate Bay or Harris
every day drinks were free at the casino
Rosanna said you gamble the minimum and
get free drinks yeah yeah they're trying
to get you to stay there and get a
little bit inebriated and on certain
days I think the buffet was free
yeah and the [__] food was [__]
great man oh you can eat shrimp like I
said they're trying to get you to like
just park there get in there just stay
there for hours and hours it's like a
lot of people who are gambling I know
every time I went and gambled I
basically ate the amount you know no
matter what I lost [__] [__] I ate more
than I was
in mine like I want to show up for 40
bucks right
that's usually what I when I would show
because it was local I would show up
with 40 and I made sure that I ate four
eight and drank forty dollars worth of
[__] so it didn't matter if I lost that
forty dollars yeah because I paid for it
I paid for the food and the drink right
because if you'd eaten at a restaurant
you would have spent that anyway yeah
and then eating at the restaurant and
then [__] drinking the drinks are
kind of weak but you just keep drinking
them right you're gonna get your fill
yeah and like I said I think it's to
their advantage for you to be like a
little bit inebriated yeah because you
lose your inhibitions and you're just
kind of like [__] it I'm gonna put all
this money you know I've gone like that
to you so I just show up with 40 bucks I
show up 40 bucks and [__] could just eat
and drink and eat and drink and [__]
play and eat and eat drink and so it
didn't matter I I paid for my good time
and I and yeah you just had it for the
food and the drink yeah yeah
um yeah xanadas said steak dinners for
6.99 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
what they do everything in there is
engineer I don't know if this is still
true but I remember hearing like for a
long time that it's like um casinos like
they don't have any windows and they
don't have any clocks in there and [__]
like that so you just go in there and
eat and get free drinks and just keep
playing and like they don't really want
you to leave they want you to just like
Park in there and stay in there for
hours and hours
granther says I would make it rain on
the girls bringing me free drinks 20
bucks every time they came my way
needless to say they would be back every
10 minutes
like I said you'd probably like [__]
falling over in there and [__] like that
but yeah so um man you guys remember the
back of our table
baccarat baccarat yeah back of rat is
that what it's called it ends with the
team in Mississippi be nothing but just
a big [__] gaggle of Chinese dudes
and Chinese girls playing that game they
[__] love that game I don't even know
how to playback not a word not a word of
[__] English
it's all Chinese gone and and nobody
else played it except them
that's moving things through the ceiling
on wires and [__] yeah yeah I don't even
I don't know there was a lot of money
they were [__] gambling a lot of
money it wasn't little [__] thousands
I can't imagine having the kind of money
where you just kind of go and like
[__] drop thousands of dollars on one
card hand or something like that that's
just mind-blowing to me that you could
just like afford to lose it yeah cause
holy [__] I don't even want to put 20
bucks down I'm like I could I could buy
like food with that I don't really I was
watching them play it but I couldn't
understand it
yeah I don't really I don't know the
rules I couldn't understand what they
were doing I don't know the rules I mean
I do know a lot of the um you know the
rules of the other games but baccarat I
don't I don't actually know how to play
that the ones in Biloxi if you didn't
know how to play the game they would
teach you how to play the game
they had dealers there that would teach
you the rules oh that's neat yeah what
if they do that in Vegas probably not
they're just like no teaching the rules
and then they let you play you're on
your own yeah now uh you could just play
you show up you play as soon as you
started gambling you didn't know how you
didn't have to know how to play it at
all you can say look I don't know how to
play this game is this what you do sir
put how much you want to bet okay put
that down there and we'll do this this
is the easiest way and he and he's kind
of gambling for you right and explaining
to you why you which I don't know who's
comfortable with that and then we didn't
do that with blackjacks now you can
double down now if you want to double
down you put money here and then we'll
run it like that it's like running two
hands at once yeah because you they
won't let you mess up
what would you do because I go ahead and
do this and do this and this let's see
how it goes so you don't have to know
the game they'll teach you the game as
you're going
I stolen I don't think I'd be good at it
what yeah like I said you show I don't
know how to play this game and they'll
walk you through it the only time
they'll tell you well this is what I
would do you could do this or this and
I'd do this if I was you okay they'll
walk you through it and you there you go
you won you know this
the only time that I've ever gambled was
me I was with some friends and we ended
up going in Daytona they have um a dog
track like a dog racing track like
that's right near the NASCAR track and
we ended up going there for whatever
reason I don't remember why we ended up
there but um but we bet on some dog
races
I did win a little bit of money and
honestly like I didn't know [__] about
[__] and I was just like looking at the
thing and I was just like I'm just gonna
pick the dogs that I think their names
are the best
and I actually ended up because you know
I just I was like oh that's a neat name
and I actually ended up winning a little
bit of money I think if I were to get
into bet on animals and racings I would
bet on I would bet along with somebody
else who knew what the [__] was going on
yeah yeah so who are you gonna bet on a
horse like I don't know anything about
this you go oh yeah I gotta win although
sometimes you have like beginner's luck
and sometimes it's better just like not
overthink it I think that's probably why
I won some the first time I went because
I just wasn't thinking about it I would
just find somebody who's who's a
well-known Gambler there and just bet
with whatever he's gonna do right that's
that's probably the best way to go
yeah Xanax said practice online before
going into a real Casino Pro tip yeah
that's a that's a good thing online
[__] right like back in the day sure
they taught you right there also it says
horse racing is Big too Kentucky Derby
makes big money in Nevada yeah it's like
I said it in Daytona they don't have
horse racing there but they do have dog
racing
um that's right near the thing and you
are actually allowed to bet on it but I
don't it's weird because I don't know I
don't think gambling is technically
legal but they do have the dog racing
track there so I'm not really sure like
how they get around it you know what I
mean because you can't actually go and
bet there
but
I don't know I don't even know if it's
still there or not you do realize I'm
smoking a turkey down there
are you yeah no you didn't tell me yeah
I got a turkey down there look at all
the secretive [__] you're doing yeah
I got that food Secrets 200 I think it's
a 260 degrees
[__] uh Liquid Smoke on it it's
covered man that one you made before was
like really good yeah and I got the
Liquid Smoke on the inside of the foot
and I pulled the skin away and I got it
in between the skin and the [__] meat
trying to that [__] is going to be
smoked man smoked in the oven well you
know it's still good though when's that
gonna be ready I don't know you don't
know oh I gotta go down here check it oh
okay probably a long time
that's real low temperature how long are
we talking about probably another three
four hours probably I don't know oh so
it's gonna be like bedtime before yeah
yeah well I got pork already done you
know if you want more pork oh okay yeah
a lot of that yeah because we had a
quesadilla earlier yeah the turkey
wasn't really meant for today oh okay
why'd you tell me about it now I'm kind
of like tonight it'll probably be right
be ready all right well well like I said
which all we got to do tonight we got to
watch a haunting so I can take notes on
that but yeah so um I'm really so like I
said xanada I'm really glad that you
sent me this movie because I hadn't seen
it in a long time Tom had never seen it
that was like really
um happy to re-watch it because it's
it's honestly I remember really really
liking it back in the day but like
watching it again I was like man this is
like way better than I remembered like
all the acting performances are great
it's just like a great yeah great movie
and like when I started researching it
and finding out like how close this
stuff that happened in the movie like
was to the actual [__] that happened was
like really interesting too so you know
I don't think I covered like a lot of it
but you know it's it's interesting I
want you to lay it lay them trigger
Parts out take photographs of any kind
of Mark things and numbers on them so I
can see what they are and that buffer
take it out of that buffer spring and
the face of that buffer it's going to
have a letter and a number or something
written in the front take a picture of
that it's I think it has a white base on
it I want to figure out what kind of
buffer that is that might be a Tungsten
buffer I don't know what you have in
your rifle the way it is now that might
be a better buffer
I don't they're color coded from PSE I'm
not sure what white means I'll have to
uh we can look into it yeah but that's
an upgrade those are upgrade parts
I just don't know if they're for five
five six
I'm pretty sure that [__] hit I'm
pretty sure that
that trigger and Hammer and everything
in there is is a PSA enhanced trigger I
think it's probably a five pound trigger
so I'd install that
they got online tutorials how did all
you need is a hammer a punch and a towel
or something or a pillow something to
lay the [__] rifle on you can just
tap those
tap those pins right out through the
lower receiver and the trigger just
comes out and it's easy you just [__]
take the hammer and the spring and it
it's all got to go in the right way and
then you just push the pins through it
it
one little module at a time it's easy
but the you see the tutorials online how
to do it there's your I think that's
your trigger right there
yeah Xander said a great movie it's one
of my favorites he said earlier that it
was uh in his top five favorite films so
yeah if you have not seen Casino uh you
know the Martin Score says you filmed I
would definitely recommend it it is very
it is similar to Goodfellas but I don't
know I've seen some people like it
better than Goodfellas I'm not sure I
haven't seen Good Fellas I think it's
about the same like I said they're
thematically very similar but they're
kind of like different enough that I
mean they have their own thing going on
so I don't know but it's still like a
great movie and I was glad to re-watch
it so tomorrow is Monday and that means
it's time for haunting Mondays and we
are done with season five so we're
actually moving on to season six so
we're gonna be doing season six episode
one which is called marked by evil not
to be confused with one that we already
did which was called stalked by evil
yeah because I'm sitting there going I'm
looking I was like marked by evil that
sounds awfully familiar I'm like we've
already done that but then I looked and
I was like oh we did stalked by evil
which I think was season four x-rated
versus called [__] [__] by you
you know all about that
the lights are back here yeah we got our
little uh and they have like little
colored gels too that like you can put
over them confusers on there right now
just kind of soft and light yeah we got
all kind of like yeah we got all kind of
we've been spending all this money like
on yeah right like Tom got me a whole
new uh another shipment of dresses that
came in today so those are all hanging
up I even got like a um like a what do
you call it like a clothes uh like a
garment rack yeah it's like that rolls
around so I could hang because I'm
running out of room in that [__]
closet for like all these outfits and
stuff so I'm gonna and I got a bunch
more wig stands and all that kind of
[__] so we're gonna like make like a
whole [__] costume area in here and
[__] like that yeah so that'll be good I
can at least get that [__] closet
cleaned out because it's it's terrible
in there like shit's just making it it's
just piled on everything
boxes in there filled with just like
some of my old stuff like we need to get
that up in the damn it wouldn't fit up
through that [__] I don't think it's
gonna fit in that okay yeah we have like
an attic space technically we've got
this other closet we can put them in
yeah we can put them in there I guess
okay
there's more room in that closet and
we're not doing the t-shirts as much as
we used to be doing so we can free up
some space in there
yeah we'll move it's almost time to do a
t-shirt shipment man it's been forever
yeah we probably need to design another
one I just haven't had time to do one
she's been so busy I need an idea also
yeah you know maybe maybe we'll do
should we do like The Honky Kong one
yeah yeah
we can do that can I make you look like
a little um like a little 8-bit
character put Donkey Kong on it don't
put me on it just put down that would be
much funnier if it was your face though
it wouldn't work yeah what I could make
it work so you're gonna make it look
like an old [__] 16-bit video game my
face yeah like with a little bald head
and a little beard yeah but with a
little gorilla body yeah I could do that
okay yeah that's what I was thinking
like a real picture of my face on it no
no no no I'm gonna make it look like an
8-bit okay character okay okay yeah like
a gorilla but with your face on yeah
honky calm yeah yeah okay and then I'll
do it with the font yeah okay like the
Donkey Kong font like the looks all
cartoony and [__]
that would be funny that would be funny
yeah
the vanilla gorilla yeah yeah
now see that one I could do like that
one I could do like a drawing of your
face but it's like Magilla Gorilla but
with your head but see that would be fun
and it has to be white also instead what
wasn't megilla gorilla was he purple
he's purple purple yeah I thought he was
purple yeah you can't be purple you can
just be white well it's going to be only
in white anyway that's true white on a
black shirt we could yeah we can do two
versions we'll do we'll do vanilla and
hockey Kong I mean hockey Kong is
funnier but yeah I mean they're both
pretty funny and we still haven't done
abdominals no man either yeah but
these are all like all of the shirt
ideas that I have are all just like
funny cartoons of you yeah
you know what I mean yeah but uh but
yeah I'll I'll get around to it one of
these days all right so yeah thank you
everybody for dropping by thank you
again xanada for sending us the movie
that was really nice of you and uh
tomorrow we're gonna be on at 7 30 p.m
Eastern Standard Time talking about
haunting like I said it's gonna be
marked by evil not stalked by evil it's
two completely different things so
that's what we're gonna be talking about
tomorrow night so hopefully you can all
join us for that and we'll see you again
tomorrow evening good night